the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right welcome thank you so much for
coming
I'm Jeremy Kepner I'm a fellow at
Lincoln Laboratory I lead the
supercomputing Center there which means
I have the privilege of working everyday
with pretty much everyone at MIT I think
I have the best job at MIT because I get
to help me wall pursue your research
research dreams and as a result of that
I get an opportunity to sort of see what
a really wide range of folks are doing
and observe patterns between what
different folks are doing so with that
I'll get I'll get started this is meant
to be some initial motivational material
why you should be interested in learning
about this mathematics this mathematics
of big data and how it relates to
machine learning and other really
exciting topics it is a math course we
will be going over a fair amount of math
but we really work hard to make it very
accessible to people so we start out
with a really elementary mathematical
concept here probably one that hopefully
most of Lee most of you are familiar
with it's sort of the basic concept of a
circle right and I bring that up because
many of us know you know many ways to
state this mathematically right it's
it's all the points that are equal
distance from from a particular point
there's other ways to describe it but
this is sort of a basic mathematical
concept of a circle that many of us have
grown up with but of course the other
thing we know is that right and this is
sort of kind of the the big idea is that
although I can write down an equation
for a circle which is the equation for a
perfect ideal circle we know that such
things don't actually exist in nature
there is no true perfect circle in
nature even this circle that we've drawn
here it has pixels if I zoomed in on it
if I zoomed in on enough it wouldn't
look like a circle at all it would look
like a series of blocks it would look
and so that approximation process right
where we have a mathematical concept of
an ideal circle right but we know that
there are not really they don't really
exist in nature but we understand that
it is worthwhile to think about these
mathematical ideals manipulate them and
then take the results of those
manipulation back into the real world
that's a really productive way to think
about things and really the basis for a
lot of what we do here at MIT this
concept you know is essentially the
basis of sort of modern or not even or
ancient Western thought on mathematics
if you remember your history courses
this concept of ideal shapes and ideal
circles is sort of the foundation of
platonic mathematics some 2500 years ago
and at the time though that they were
developing that concept this idea that
that there are ideal shapes out there
and that thinking about them and
manipulate them was a more effective way
to reason about the real world you know
there was a lot of skepticism you could
imagine 2,500 years ago someone's
walking around saying I believe there's
these things called ideal circles in
ideal squares and ideal shapes but they
don't actually exist in nature that
would probably not be well-received in
fact it was not well-received many of
those those philosophers who were
thinking about this were we're very
negatively negatively received in fact
if you want to learn about how negative
the response was to this I encourage you
to go and read the allegory of the cave
which is essentially the story of these
philosophers talking about how they're
trying to bring the light of this
knowledge to the broader world and how
they essentially
killed because of it because people
don't want want to see it so that
struggle that we they experience 2500
years ago it exists today you will you
as as people at MIT will try and bring
mathematical concepts into environments
for people like I don't see why that's
relevant and you will experience you
know negative inputs but you should rest
assured that this is a good bet it's
worked well for thousands of years you
know it's what I base my career on
people ask well what's the basis of it
well I'm just sort of betting on math
here that's been a good it's been a good
tool and so this is why we're beginning
to think of this way when we talk about
big data and machine learning sort of
really looking at the fundamentals what
are the ideals that we that we need in
order to effectively reason about the
problems that we're facing today in the
virtual world right and the fact that
you know this mathematical concepts you
know describe the natural world so well
and also described in you know in the
virtual world is sometimes called the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics you can look that up but
people talk about math why does it doe
do a such a good job of describing so
many of things and people say well they
don't really know but it's it seems to
be a good bit of luck that it happens
that way so you know this is circles and
that gets us you know a certain way but
in most of the fields that that we work
with and I would say that in almost any
introductory course that you take in
college whatever the discipline is
whether it be you know chemistry or
mechanical engineering or Electrical
Engineering or physics or biology the
basic fundamental theoretical ideas that
they will introduce to you will be the
concept of a linear model so there we
have a linear model right and why do we
like linear models and again it can be
physics it can be simple as F equals MA
or in chemistry you can be some kind of
chemical rate equation
or in mechanical engineering there's you
know it can be basic concepts of
friction the reason we like these basic
linear models is because we can project
right I know that if that solid line
represents what I believed you know I
have evidence to support that that that
is correct then I feel pretty good about
projecting maybe where I don't have data
or into a new domain so linear models
allow us to do this this reasoning and
that's why in almost every in the first
few weeks of almost any introductory
course they begin with these linear
models because they have proven to be so
effective now there are many nonlinear
phenomena there tremendously important
ok and and as a person who deals with
large-scale computation you know those
are a staple of what people do but in
order to do nonlinear calculations or
reason about things non linearly it
usually requires a much more complicated
analysis and much more computation much
more data and so our ability to
extrapolate is very limited ok it's very
it's very limited so here I am talking
about the benefits of ideal well
thinking mathematically talking about
you know linearity what does this have
to do with big data well and and and
machine learning so we would like to be
able to do the same things that we've
been able to do in other fields in this
sort of new emerging field of big data
and this often deals with data that
doesn't look like the traditional you
know measurements we see in in science
this can be data that has to do with
words or images pictures of people other
types of things that don't feel like the
kinds of data that we traditionally deal
with in science and engineering but we
know we want to use linear models so how
are we going to do that how can we take
this concept of Lin
which has been so powerful across so
many disciplines and bring them to this
field that that just feels completely
different in time the kinds of times of
data that we have so to begin with I
need to refresh for you what it really
means to be linear before I showed you a
line and hence line linear but
mathematically linearity means something
much deeper and so here's an equation
that you may have first seen in
elementary school we basically have 2
times 3 plus 4 is equal to 2 times 3
plus 2 times 4 that is called the
distributive property
it basically says multiplication
distributes over addition and this is
the fundamental reason why I would say
mathematics works in our world right if
this wasn't true very early on in the
earliest days of inventing mathematics
it would not have been very useful right
you know they say that I have you know 2
of 3 plus 4 of something ok and then I
can sort of change it and do in this
other way that's really what makes
mathematical mathematics useful and from
a deeper perspective the distributive
property is basically what makes math
linear this is the property that if this
property holds then we can reason about
a system linearly now you're very
familiar with this type of mathematics
but there's other types of mathematics
so if you will allow me hopefully you
will let me just replace those
multiplication symbols and addition
symbols with the sort of funny circle
times and circle plus and we'll get to
why I'm going to do that because it
turns out that while you have been done
most of your careers with traditional
arithmetic multiplication and addition
the kind you would do on your calculator
have done in in elementary school it
turns out there's other pairs of
operations that also obey
property this distributive property and
therefore allow us to potentially build
linear models of very different types of
data using this property so as I
mentioned the sort of the classic two
are you know circle plus is just equal
to regular arithmetic addition as we
show in the first line and circle x is
equal to regular arithmetic
multiplication so those are sort of the
standard ones and by far this pair you
know this is the most common pair that
we use you know across the world today
but there are others
so for existence I can replace the plus
operation with Max and the
multiplication operation with addition
okay and the above distributive equation
will still hold right that's very little
confusing and I often get confused that
you know addition and you know the
multiplication is no addition but this
is this pair sometimes referred to as
Max Plus you'll sometimes hear about as
Max Plus algebra is actually very
important in machine learning and neural
networks this is actually sort of the
the the back end of the rectified linear
unit is essentially this this operation
if you didn't understand what that meant
that's okay we'll get to that later it's
very important in finance there's
certain finance operations that rely on
this type of mathematics there are other
pairs also so here's one I can replace
addition with Union and multiplication
with intersection right now this that
also obeys that linear property this is
essentially a pair of operations that
you know anytime you make a transaction
and work with what's called a relational
database that's the mathematical
operation a pair that's sitting inside
it it's why those databases work it
allows us to reason about queries which
are just a series of intersections and
using unions and and reorder them and
Rianne
in such a way well this isn't in
databases is called query planning and
if that property wasn't true we wouldn't
be able to do that so this is a deep
deep property of that so you know these
these we can put all different types of
pairs in here and and reason about them
linearly and this is why that many many
of the of the systems we use today work
and so this class is about so really
exposing that that really the
mathematics that allows us to think
linearly about data that we haven't
really thought of as maybe obeying some
kind of linear model this is essentially
the critical point of this class so it
goes beyond that though so hopefully
you'll allow me to replace those numbers
with letters right so that's sort of
basic algebra there that just for
refresher the previous equation you know
we had a equals to B equals three C
equals four but we're not limited to
these variables or these these letters
to being just simple scalar numbers in
this case real numbers or integers or
something like that they can be other
things too so for instance a B and C
could be spreadsheets and that's
something we'll go over with extensively
in a class so that I can basically have
a B and C be whole spreadsheets of data
and the linear equation will still hold
in fact that's probably the key concept
in big data is the necessity to reason
about data as whole collections in
transforming whole collections going and
looking at things one element in time at
a time is is essentially the thing that
is extremely difficult to do when you
have large amounts of data
a B and C can be database tables right
those doing differ too much from
spreadsheets and as I talked to you you
know in the previous slide you know that
Union intersection pair naturally lines
up and we can do reason about whole
tables in a database using linear
properties they can be matrices I think
for those of you who have had linear
algebra or matrix mathematics that would
have been the first example right when I
substituted the a B and C and had the
these linear equations often in many of
the sciences we think about you know
matrix operations and linearity as sort
of being a couple together and through
the do allottee between matrices and and
graphs and networks we can represent
graphs and networks through matrices
anytime you work with a neural network
you're representing that network as a
matrix and of course all these equations
apply there as well and can reason about
those systems linearly so that provides
a little motivation there as it was we
like to say enough about me let me tell
you about my my book so this will be the
text that will be use in the class we
are not going to go through the full
text but we have printed out copies of
the first sort of seven chapters that we
will go through and we will hand those
out later when you when you when you do
do the class so let me now switch gears
a little bit and talk about how this
relates to I think one of the most
wonderful breakthroughs that we have
seen where I've seen in my career and
many of my colleagues here at MIT have
seen which is what's been going on in
machine learning right which is which is
it's sort of beat it's not it's not hype
there's a real real there there and it's
tremendously exciting so
give you a little history basic history
of this field so in a certain sense
before 2010 machine learning looked like
this and then sort of after 2015 it kind
of looks like this so when people talk
about the hype in machine learning or AI
really deep neural networks are the
elephant inside the machine learning
snake and they have that has stormed
onto the scene in the last five years
and basically allowed us to do things
that you know we had almost taken for
granted were a pop impossible in just
the fact that you're able to talk to
computers and they can understand you
that we can have computers that can see
in the way you know or at least in a way
that approximate the way humans do these
are really almost technological miracles
that for those of us who've been working
on this field for 50 years we get almost
literally given up on and then all of a
sudden it became possible so let me give
you a little sense of a reprieve for
this field and it's and its roots so
machine learning like any field is
defined as a set of techniques and
problems when you ask what defines a
field you ask well what are the problems
that they work on that other fields
don't really work on and what are the
techniques they employ that really are
not really you know be employed by
others so you know the core techniques
you know as I've mentioned earlier are
these neural networks these are meant to
crudely approximate maybe the way humans
think about problems we have these
circles which are neurons they have
connections to other neurons
you know those connections have
different weights associated with them
as information comes in they get
multiplied by those weights they get
some together and if they pass certain
thresholds or criteria then they send a
signal on to another neuron and this is
to a certain degree how we believe the
human the the brain works and is a sort
of natural starting point for how do we
think about how could we make
do similar things sort of the big you
know problems that people have worked on
in in that are sort of kind of these
sort of classic problems in machine
learning our language how do we how do
we make computers understand human human
language vision how do we make computers
see pictures or explain pictures back to
us the way we would like and strategy
and games and other types of things like
that sort of how do we get them to solve
problems this is not new these core
concepts traced back to the earliest
days of the field in fact these four
figures here each one is taken from a
paper that was presented at the very
first machine learning conference in the
mid-1950s so there was a machine
learning conference in the mid-1950s it
was in Los Angeles it had four papers
presented these were the these were the
four papers and I will say that three of
them were done by folks at at MIT
Lincoln Laboratory which is where I work
and so that was the basically the neural
networks the language and vision and we
didn't play games so you know that was
that was that was that so this is this
was and you might say well why why is it
why was there so much work going on in
Lincoln Laboratory in the mid-1950s that
they would they would want to sort of
pioneer in these in these directions
Lincoln lab you know at that time people
were first building computers and
computers were very special purpose so
different organizations around the world
we're building computers seduced
different things some were doing them to
simulate you know you know
complex fluid dynamics systems you know
think about designing ships or other
types of things like that others or
airplanes others were doing them to say
like what Alan Turing was doing to break
codes and our task was to help people
who were watching radar scopes make
decisions right how could we watch sent
how could humans you know be innate
could computers and able humans to watch
more sensors to you know and see what
their what they're going to how could we
do that so at Lincoln Laboratory we were
building special-purpose computers to do
this and we built the first large
computer with reliable fast memory this
system had 4096 bytes of memory which at
the time people thought was too much
what could you possibly do with 4096
numbers the human brain of course right
that's enough right most of us can
remember five six seven digits right so
a computer that can remember 4096
numbers should be able to do things like
language and vision and strategy so why
not so they went out and they started
working on these problems okay and and
but but Lincoln Laboratory being an
Applied Research Laboratory it is we are
required to get answers to our sponsors
and you know a few years timeframe we if
problems are going to take longer than
that then they really are the are the
purview of the basic research community
universities and it became apparent
pretty early on that this problem was
going to be more difficult it was not
going to be solved you know in in a few
unit right away so we did what we often
do is we partnered we found some bright
young people at MIT people just like
yourselves in this case we found a young
young professor named Marvin Minsky who
and we said why don't you go
and get some of your friends together
and create a meeting where you can lay
out what the fundamental challenges are
this field and then we will figure out
how to get that funded so that you can
go and do that research and that was the
famous Dartmouth AI conference which
kicked off the field and the the person
leading this group Oliver Selfridge at
Lincoln Laboratory basically arranged
for that conference to happen and then
subsequently arranged for the what would
became the MIT AI lab that was founded
by Professor Minsky and likewise
professor Selfridge also realized that
we would need more computing power so he
he left Lincoln Laboratory informed what
was called project Mac which became the
laboratory for computer science and then
those two entities later merged 30 years
later to become csail so that was sort
of the initial thing now it was pretty
clear that when this problem was handed
off to the basic research community that
there was a feeling that this problem
these problems would be solved in about
a decade so we were really thinking by
the mid 1960s is when these problems
would be really solved so it's kind of
like giving someone an assignment right
you all are given assignments by
professors and they give you a week to
do it but it took a little longer in
this case it took five weeks or in this
case five decades to solve this problem
and but we have we've we've now really
using those techniques we've made
tremendous progress on those problems
but we don't know why it works so let me
show you a little bit what we have
learned and then this course will
explore the deeper mathematics to help
us gain insight we still don't know why
it works at least we can lay the
foundations and maybe you can figure it
out so here I am 50 years later a person
from Lincoln Laboratory saying
alright question one has been answered
here's question two ha why does this
work and hopefully you can you can begin
be the generation figures out hopefully
it'll take less than 50 years
historically this type once we know how
it works
it usually takes about 20 years to
figure out why so I mean impasse but but
maybe maybe you know some people are
smarter and they'll figure it out faster
so this is what a neural network looks
like on the left you have your input in
this case a vector Y 0 it's just these
dots that are called features the you
know what is a feature anything can be a
feature that is the power of neural
networks is they don't require you to
sort of a priori state what the inputs
can be they can be anything if people
people have said well you know neural
network to machine learn it's just curve
fitting yeah but it's confer fitting
without domain knowledge because the
domain knowledge is so costly and
expensive to create that having a
general system that can do this is
really what's so powerful so the inputs
you know so we have an input feature it
could be a vector which we call Y sub 0
and that can just be an image right the
canonical thing being an image of a cat
right and that can just be the the
pixels values just sort of rolled out
into a vector and there will be the
inputs and then we have a series of
layers these are called the hidden
layers the circles are often referred to
as neurons ok and each line connecting
each dot has a value associated with it
a weight and the strength of connection
between any two neurons is given by that
weight and then ultimately output in
this case the the output classification
the series of blue dots there are the
different possible category
so if I put in a cat picture one of
those dots would be cat maybe one would
be dog maybe one would be apple orange
whatever whatever I whatever I desired
and the whole idea is that if I put in a
picture of a cat you know and I set all
these values correctly then the the dot
ass corresponding to cat will end up
with the highest the highest score right
and then I mentioned earlier that you
know each one of these neurons collects
inputs and if it's above a certain
threshold it then chooses to pass on
information to the next and that's where
these B values which are vectors those
are just the thresholds associated with
each one of those it's a vector one
value associated each one of those that
does those this this entire system can
be represented relatively simply with
one equation which is that why I plus 1
which is the next vector in the layer ok
can be computed by the previous vector Y
I matrix multiplied by the weights W so
whenever you see sort of transformations
from one set of neurons to the next
layer you should think oh I have a
matrix that represent all those weights
and I'm going to multiply it by the
vector to give the next one then we
apply these thresholds all right and
then you know so we add these these the
the B eyes and then we have a function
that we pass it through
typically the this h function has been
given the name rectified linear unit it
really just it's much simpler than that
it's just if the value is greater than
that comes out of this this matrix
multiplying is if the value is greater
than zero don't touch it just let it
pass through if it's less than zero make
it zero right you know it's pretty
pretty complicated name for for for a
very simple function that's actually
critical if you didn't have that H
function this nonlinear function there
then we could roll up all of these
together and we just have one big matrix
equation right so that's really
considered a pretty important part of it
so that's pretty much what's going on
when you want to know what the big deal
is of neural networks that's all that's
going on it's just that equation the
challenge is we don't know what the W's
and the B's are and we don't know how
many layers there should be and we don't
know how many you know neurons there
should be in each layer and although the
features can be arbitrary picking the
right ones do matter and picking the
right categories to matter so when
people talk about I do machine learning
or I'm off you know working on they're
basically playing with all of these
parameters to try and find the ones that
will work best for their problem and
there's a lot of trial there and you'll
hear about there's now systems that try
and use machine learning to do that
process automatically you know this is
from how do you make machines that learn
how to do machine learning the basic
approach is a trial and error approach I
take a whole bunch of pictures of cats
that I know have cats in them okay in
other and other things right and I
randomly set all those weights and
thresholds and I put in the vector and I
see what the system my guess what I
think the number of layers and neurons
and all it should be and I run it
through the system and I get an estimate
for what I think or a calculation for
what I think the these final values
should be and I compare it with the
truth that is I just basically subtract
it and then I use those Corrections to
very carefully adjust the weights
basically with the last weights first I
what's called back propagate these
little changes to try and make a better
guess on what these weights should be so
if you hear the term back propagation
that's that process of taking those
differences and using them to adjust
these weights by about 0.01 percent at a
time
and so and then we just do this over and
over again until eventually we get a set
of weights that that we think does the
problem well enough for our purpose so
that's called back propagation right
once we have the set of weights and we
have a new picture that we want to know
what it is we drop it in there and we
get it tells us it's a cat or a dog
whatever that forward step is called
inference these are two words you'll
hear you know frequently in machine
learning back propagation and inference
and that's all there is to it there's
really no nothing else to that if you
can understand this equation you'll be
way ahead of most people and machine
learning you know that's you know
there's lots of people will understand
about all the software and the packages
and the data all of them are just doing
that and I'd say this is one of the most
powerful ways to be ahead in your field
is to actually understand the
mathematical principles because then the
software and what it's doing is is is
much clearer and other people who don't
understand these mathematical principles
they're really kind of guessing they're
like oh well I I do this and I throw
this module and they're like they don't
really know that all that's doing is
making adjustments to these various
equations you know how many different
layers they are and stuff like that now
why is this important me like well what
does it matter as I said before we have
this system it works but we don't know
why well why is it important to know why
well there's two reasons one is that if
we want to be able to apply this
incredible innovation to other domains
so many of you probably want to do that
many of you want to see how can I apply
machine learning to something else other
than language or vision or some of these
other sort of standard problems I kind
of need some theory to know like okay if
I have a problem it's kind of like this
one over here and I change in this way
you know you know it there's a good
chance it'll work there's some basis for
my for why I'm gonna try something right
right now there's a lot of trial and
error just like well it's an idea but if
you can have some math that says you
know I think that will probably work
that really is a great way to guide
guide your
reasoning died your efforts another
reason is that so here's a picture of a
very cute poodle right and the machine
learning system correctly identifies it
as poodle one thing we realize is that
the way you and I see that picture is
actually very very different than the
way the neural network sees that picture
all right and in fact I can make changes
to that picture that are imperceptible
to you or me but will completely change
how the neural network that is given a
neural network I can basically make it
think anything right and so for instance
is a famous paper and they got the
system to think that that was an ostrich
right and you can you can basically show
this for anything right
so what's called robust AI a robust
machine learning machine learning that
can't be you know tricked it's gonna
become more and more important and again
having a deeper understanding of the
theory is very very critical with that
so how are we gonna do this what's
what's that what's the main concept that
we are going to go through in this class
this has mostly been motivational but
how are we gonna understand the data at
a deeper level you know what's the
what's the big idea and the big idea is
sort of captured you know now in this
should've won I apologized this I
charged slide which is what we call it
declarative mathematically rigorous data
so we have this mathematical concept
called an associative array and its
course not bonding algebra that
basically encompasses the data you would
put in databases the data you would put
in graphs the data you would put a
matrices and it makes it all a linear
system and the key operations are
outlined there at the bottom if you
recall we have our basic little addition
or multiplication and then what's going
to be very important probably the real
sort of workhorse for this and I didn't
show it before which is called
essentially array multiplication or
matrix multiplication and that's the LAT
farm on the right there which we often
abbreviate just with no symbol just a
bee
but if we really want to explicitly call
out that it's matrix multiplication is a
combination of both multiplication
addition we put in what we call the
punch-drunk emoji which is a + dot times
you're probably all young enough that
you don't even remember emojis when they
had to type them out with just little
characters and we didn't have icons
right so that meant that meant you went
to the bar and lost to the fight right
so so so but anyway that's that's really
going to be the workhorse of what we're
doing here
you